every year through the annual budget
process Yelp thoroughly reviews its
financial resources and the Strategic
goals that serve to advance the
University's mission
we carefully consider new and continuing
opportunities for supporting students
faculty and staff across the university
and for partnering with our home City of
New Haven
the purpose of this video is to explain
where funding for the budget comes from
how it's allocated and how we make those
decisions
[Music]
the university budget falls into two
basic categories first is the operating
budget which is the ongoing cost of what
it takes to run a university on a
day-to-day basis throughout the year the
other is the capital budget and the
capital budget is what it takes to be
able to build new buildings or renovate
existing buildings for their use one key
to the budget is that this is incredibly
collaborative it involves input from so
many different places in the university
all of whom are working together to try
to develop a budget by late spring that
can be approved by the corporation and
then move forward to Define spending in
the coming year this begins with a set
of parameters that are given to each
budgetary unit that Define things like
what in what we anticipate inflation
will be what we anticipate the endowment
return will be those are then brought
back to What's called the the budget
Advisory Group the budget Advisory Group
is comprised of the Provost those in the
Provost office senior administrative
leadership in the Department of Finance
and operations as well as several
faculty that provide prospective and
input to understand both the financial
side as well as the academic side of all
these budget requests we work to create
a budget which reflects our current
needs but also reflects the needs to be
financially responsible into future
Generations external revenue for the
operating budget comes from a variety of
sources for the past year 2022 which
runs from July 1st 2021 until June 30th
2022 that Revenue contributes just over
4.7 billion dollars to the budget
it might be surprising to see the
tuition room and board comprise a
relatively small slice of this overall
Revenue it's just 450 million dollars or
about 10 percent of the University
budget
that's the net amount after 50 percent
of the gross tuition room and board is
returned in the form of financial aid
two biggest sources of income are
spending from the endowment which
contributes about 1.6 billion or 33
percent and Medical Services income
which is 1.4 billion or 29 percent of
the total budget
the third largest contributor of Revenue
is Grants and contracts at 921 million
dollars or 19 of the total budget
yields annual operating budget is a
combination of all the sources of
revenue we anticipate for the coming
year as well as all of the expenses or
spending we anticipate for the coming
year every year the anticipated expenses
of the annual budget are typically close
to the amount of anticipated Revenue for
the fiscal year 2022 expected expenses
net of internal revenue are about 4.6
billion dollars Yale seeks to improve
the World by creating knowledge and
sharing that knowledge and that's a
mission that's carried out by and four
people
so it makes sense that the biggest
category of expenses at Yale are the
salaries and benefits for the people who
work here the nearly 5 000 faculty and
about 10 000 staff in the fiscal year
2022 budget salaries and benefits total
2.9 billion dollars or nearly two-thirds
of the University's budget
included in the 2.9 billion dollars is
about 700 million dollars in employee
benefit costs most of which over 90
percent are health and retirement
related
non-sowary expenses account for another
1.5 billion dollars of the budget
these include a wide range of costs
including utilities medical supplies and
services
lab supplies and equipment
Consulting and Professional Services
Acquisitions of books periodicals and
artworks and many other costs
you can find more details on these
expenses and much more about the
operating budget in the University
budget book which is available to all
faculty staff and students on the
provost's website
the yield budget process allows each
schooling unit to bring forward their
annual budget in line with their
strategic initiatives that they've put
forth in a long-range plan for approval
this is an opportunity for those that
get promotional funds to ask for funding
for ideas that they have put forward in
line with the mission of their school or
admission of the University once the
officer's Deans and unit leaders along
with their lead administrators put
together their proposals we meet with
the budget Advisory Group during the
months of March and April everyone comes
forward and does a presentation
decisions are made really based on the
operational needs of the unit we also
look at the president and Provost
strategic initiatives for the next five
to ten years and we also look at what
ideas will be the strong have the
strongest outcomes on the University and
Advance the mission of the University we
summarize the entire budget for the
Provost who then presents it to the
president who then presented in the June
corporate operation meeting to the
trustees of Yale University for approval
once we gain approval we communicate all
that to the lead administrators the
Deans and officers for the new year and
that's happens in June and we turn over
the New Year July 1st
[Music]
obviously the budget is everything that
is the University and so it supports
everything that is in the university all
the people all the places all the
collections all the operations are
supported by this budget it involves
every aspect of what the university does
from the clinical practice to what
collections are found in the libraries
to what the salaries are for faculty and
staff what financial aid we provide to
students the most important thing the
university does is to recruit the next
generation of Scholars as we create the
community of Scholars that is Yale
University the budget is the key tool
that we utilize for that recruitment as
we further diversify our faculty and as
we develop the emerging fields that are
happening across different disciplines
it's a moment to reimagine what the
fields are to reimagine what the
university looks like what the
composition of the university is and
then to make these investments in people
and in the spaces that are needed for
those people to thrive the generosity of
our donors over multiple decades makes
it possible for us to admit students
without regard to their need without
regard to their financial circumstance
which is fundamentally an opportunity to
have the most diverse student body
possible where we can recruit students
to campus from all backgrounds
independent of what their Financial
Resources reflect that we can bring them
from really all over the world we can
create the most diverse student body
utilizing the power of the endowment to
be able to cover the costs of an
education at Yale
the University's budget has to be part
of building an inclusive workplace when
we start to think about the composition
of the organization we think about
faculty we think about students we
certainly think about the 11 000 plus
staff that are part of the community but
I also think the word Community is
what's most important to me and so the
University's budget allows us to build
community through a variety of different
ways for staff diversity it helps us to
attract Talent the University's budget
includes a large commitment to the City
of New Haven I believe our commitment is
approximately 135 million dollars over a
six-year period and as a result of that
I think it makes us the largest
university commitment to its host City
and for me that's quite exciting given
that I'm a resident and Native of the
City of New Haven the budget process is
dynamic it reflects the revenue that's
coming into the university sometimes the
endowment goes up sometimes it goes down
and we have to make adjustments
accordingly and so through the
generosity of donors over multiple years
over centuries that endowment has grown
to the point where it provides a
substantial portion of our budgetary
support that makes it possible for us to
invest in the future for us to carry out
our mission for us to support our
students and our faculty and our staff
to create a community of Scholars that
is seeking the future of academic
disciplines and thriving in all of its
missions
foreign